for the first time in a hundred and  forty years the famed Westminster Dog  Show has announced it will also feature  cats they're gonna feature cats yeah  yeah the organizers say it's an attempt  to appeal to cat lovers now here's  interesting the preliminary round of the  cat competition has already begun we are  the only show that got exclusive access  to the live live feed backstage you want  to see would you calm down  oh you calm down and that concludes our  Terrier division and here we have a rare  and beautiful bangle happy hunting  they're quite adept at gouging out  eyeballs yes and an incredible ability  to take down prey much larger than  themselves nothing brings the cats out  quite like pooling blood which we  neutral iron indeed look at those  beautiful coats  if you love blood  you